i'm not gay and that's what i said if
i'm gay hey god strike me dead
what is your advice you must have a lot
of young people that say
bo how do i get into the business how do
i accomplish what you've accomplished
what's your advice for young people you
got to just take a deep breath and give
up
don't the system is rigged against you
your hard work and talent will not pay
off
that's it good night everybody
what do you call a kid with no arms and
an eye patch
names
[Applause]
younger generation so
i just wonder for all of you uh
who are you
my aunt used to say
slow and steady wins the race
she died in a fire
and i would say people always ask me uh
because i'm tall if i play basketball
mine is worse i go i always say hey your
face is all
up
do you box
that's pretty good it was mean yeah yeah
it was before i hadn't found my way it's
so hard you have to get that laugh up
top another one is do they say how's the
weather up there and you say it's
raining and you spit in their face
taylor swift telling you to follow your
dreams is like
a lottery winner saying liquidize your
assets buy powerball tickets it works
yeah you will get you just you won't
it's
it's
at one point movies were trying to
represent reality and now reality is
representing is trying to imitate movies
representation of reality i have no idea
where i'm going with this
thank you very much um
to the other nominees in the category um
have fun at the oscars losers no
no
yeah this is my father's uh horrifying
google history okay the first sport
pretty easy is a boston guy he's looking
for bruins tickets and then it takes a
sharp left turn in the next search if we
can go okay next search
what the hell
the only thing worse than girth is
misspelling girth yeah
as a dutch absurdist uh one of the
things he does is uh he brings out a
sock puppet which is a black sock see
already i don't like him yeah
all right all right so it's a white sock
and then
uh rob you're an actor
yeah do you have a lego scene or
something no what about what if i gave
you like a scenario could you just do it
could you do like a little version of
that yeah like let's pretend that we're
all bank robbers
robbing a bank you're in charge okay and
uh we're gonna put put the gun up to the
clerk and say give me your money go for
that
wait i said look at me rob
[Applause]
when did my mother first describe gay
sex to me good question i was eight
years old
i was eight years old
she
brought me into the dining room she sat
right across the table from me
she said do you know how your father and
i love each other i said of course you
and dad love each other
more than two people in the world could
possibly love each other
she said well two men can love each
other in the exact same way that your
father and i love each other
she said what happens when two men love
each other like that
what they do is they uh
they take off all their clothes
um they get in a bed
and they [ __ ] on the bible
you guys like impressions like
impressions
why
thank you that was uh that was socrates
um
the worst thing they've said about you
uh the first comment i ever got was uh
when i was 15 it was go go gadget [ __ ]
but i can do comedy without stupid
gimmicks or anything and it can still
work so uh this is for all those comics
out there and judge this uh
what do you call a kid with no arms and
an eye patch
names
for 15 cents a day you can feed an
african
they eat pennies
thank you very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
thanks
shut up
[Applause]
what sorry i'm not the girl who plays
the girl in the movie is is fantastic
she is just great did you did you know
right away that she would be the person
you would cast yeah what is for sure
kelsey fisher who's absolutely
incredible um
i knew pretty quickly it's a story about
a shy girl and sort of every other young
actor that would come in to play the
role
played it like it felt like a confident
kid pretending to be shy and she felt
like a shy kid pretending to be
confident which is what the role is and
what shyness is you know a lot of people
think being shy is cowering in a corner
but it's really trying to speak all of
the time and not being able to but she
graduated eighth grade a week later we
filmed
the movie and then a week after she went
to her freshman year of high school and
she didn't get cast in her school play
really
well so i promised her i'd do this uh mr
donia from thoughts knows high school
[Applause]
he's old he's on
[Music]
see you just came all right
um so i'd like to read these poems for
you guys
we'll uh we'll read these poems and then
uh we'll think for a little bit get a
little contemplative then we'll go back
to the silly stuff i promise
here we go perfect in the lights exactly
what i wanted thank you so much
amazing amazing is that real or was that
not real
[Applause]
it would be that [ __ ] tweet
boom that was the
that was the widest thing we've ever
done i think and then the seats were a
little lower i know yes your leg's a bit
of a
you want him to be here yeah yeah but
we're on eye level both of you are uh
both you and i are tall that's weird i
specifically asked to be always higher
than the guests yeah yeah that i might
have heard you you've heard like
obviously oh you're tall you play
basketball
i finally heard the comeback it's not
mine but it's uh
so give me it give me it
hey bo
you're tall
do you play basketball no do you play
mini golf
are you a jockey
bo burnham for so many people was one of
the first quote-unquote internet
sensations yeah bo burnham for most
people was who but yes um
for some people i was an internet
sensation which is a term i love
yeah
maybe
gotta warn you guys though the cameras
do add a few pounds
of muscle
oh
zach stone's got muscle
oh ladies
well
this is how your arms stand when you got
lots of muscles
all right
i'm living my dreams
wow
and now it's become at least in the
mainstream
a symbol of misogyny
hey girl what
[Music]
what
[ __ ]
the song is
[Applause]
i appreciate it man
all right
he's the weirdest heckler interaction
though
you're doing a really good job in my
opinion
[Applause]